mortgage application rates plummeted to
a 22-year low last week in the latest
sign that rising interest rates have
started to temper demand in the booming
housing market but experts say plunging
demand won't quickly pull prices down
because of historically low levels of
inventory with some forecasting prices
should continue to rise throughout the
year
mortgage applications fell 6.5 from the
week before according to the mortgage
bankers association's weekly mortgage
application survey
historically high savings rates
government stimulus measures low supply
and interest rates helped ignite a home
buying frenzy during the pandemic
but signs of a slowdown have emerged as
the fed embarks on its most aggressive
interest rate hiking cycle in two
decades
according to data released last month
pending home sales slid for the sixth
consecutive month in april to the lowest
level in nearly a decade while new home
sales plunged nearly 17 from march
in april the median new house price hit
a record 450 600 soaring nearly 20
year-over-year according to the census
bureau
in a statement the mba said rising
interest rates spurred by the federal
reserve's efforts to combat inflation
have made home buying more expensive and
as a result lowered both purchase and
refinance applications to the lowest
level in 22 years
though they plunged early in the
pandemic mortgage rates have skyrocketed
since the feds started hiking rates in
april with the latest 30-year fixed-rate
mortgages averaging about 5.1 percent up
from less than 3 percent one year
earlier
in a note last week bank of america
economists told clients that
affordability has fallen to lows last
seen during the housing crisis that
spurred the great recession and warned
that low supply will likely drive prices
up another 15 this year
the latest data comes after s p core
logic reported last week that home
prices skyrocketed at the highest rate
in 35 years in march with s p dji
managing director craig lazara adding
that it's still unclear how long it will
take for price gains to start
decelerating